ci sono delle cose che a natale non
cambiano mai
per esempio comprare queste cravatte di
merda
oppure comprare quelle orrende cartoline
natalizie da regalare ai parenti ma non
sarebbe ora di cambiare non sarebbe ora
di guardare al futuro e di usare la
tecnologia per sopperire alle nostre
mancanze
direi di sì ed è per questo che
quest'anno vi propongo la mia cartolina
virtuale perché fermarsi a scrivere
auguri quando puoi raccontare una
perfetta storia di natale e la nostra
storia
come ogni anno inizia a natale ma in
particolare al cinema con l'uscita dei
rispettivi cinepanettoni di christian de
sica e massimo boldi
ovviamente anche quest'anno
accompagneranno le nostre feste con un
po di risate un pizzico di
spensieratezza pochino di vomitino anche
leggero disgusto ma quest'anno non
saranno solo due cinepanettoni ce ne
sarà anche un terzo che si chiama super
vacanze di natale santo c'ero quando
ricorre al super davanti al titolo le
cose si mettono male e che cos'è
esattamente super vacanze di natale qual
è la sua trama non ne ha una super
vacanze di natale e un mega montaggio
delle scene migliori di tutti i
cinepanettoni
non sto scherzando esce al cinema questa
cosa che tu devi uscire di casa vestirti
abbondantemente perché fa freschi lo
verso natale cercare parcheggio entrare
nel cinema e pagare dei soldi e io sto
letteralmente morendo dalla curiosità di
vederlo questa cosa è molto natalizia mi
scalda il cuore per vari motivi ma il
primo motivo è perché il trailer di
super vacanze di natale finisce con
scritto regia di paolo infine regia
secondo perché il produttore aurelio de
laurentiis
a quanto pare non è che l'abbia spiegato
benissimo a de sica e boldi cosa avrebbe
voluto fare perché bondi
minacciato legalmente di togliere il
film e de sica invece de sica mi ha
stupito perché noi ha detto
semplicemente non c'era bisogno
non c'era bisogno perché se vuoi vedere
delle clip di christian de sica in
vacanze di natale
basta cercarlo su youtube christian
bravo certo poi l'età ha preso il
sopravvento perché ha detto basta
cercare the best of christian de sica io
mi chiedo perché in inglese christian
tra l'altro signor de sica ha fatto
questa intervista durante la
presentazione del suo nuovo album
musicale natalizio oddio mary christian
l'ho capita io ancora non riesco a
concepire che de sica stesso abbia detto
andatevela a vedere su youtube questo è
uno squarcio generazionale pazzesco
perché è veramente un sacco di gente ha
già fatto dei montaggi su youtube è una
roba pazzesca da vedere al cinema
infatti mi sono immaginato seduto in
sala a vedere il film
partire con un luogo da gamer quello da
quattordicenne non poco i bassi
fortissimi e poi far partire la clip
ma non è finita qua ovviamente io le
volevo sapere di più di questo super
vacanze di natale
quindi mi sono andato a vedere le
interviste di ruffini e in queste
interviste lui ha detto di tutto ha
detto di essere un superfan di
cinepanettoni ha detto che massimo boldi
e il team italiano è come pensare che
ted nudo ma non ci pensi un orso eco
molti uguale o di ed scorretto del
cinema italiano e poi non una ma due
ciliegine natalizie per questa cartolina
è riuscito a dire cioè il paradosso è
che queste ci sono sempre stati anche un
pochino accusati e tacciati di volgarità
e seconda ciliegina queste interviste
dove cercava in tutti i modi di
giustificare il montaggio che ha portato
al cinema
lui le ha fatte con addosso la maglietta
di fantozzi
abbiamo finalmente toccato il fondo del
cinema italiano ce l'abbiamo fatta
ragazzi sono molto contento di questo
traguardo grazie mille grazie mille a
tutti io andrò a vederlo film mi
raccomando andrò a vederlo tutto quattro
perché sono strasbourg ioso noi dobbiamo
essere testimoni di questa cosa nella
storia italiana dobbiamo essere
testimoni del cinema italiano per il
primo montaggio né al cinema
ruffini io ti aspetto lo voglio vedere e
ne riparleremo
ne riparleremo sicuramente grazie mille
e buon natale a tutti
[Musica]